[Music]
ah
you know man
oh it's been a bit
but have some
um more brendan shop stuff oh my god
with this guy
yeah
he doesn't stop does he bert kreischer
was on tiger belly
and here's what happened we can't i
can't come over and do a pool thing yeah
no we'll do how about fourth of july
we'll have a big fourth of july party
you will you can you you can you have
one girls yeah i will yeah well i'm home
fourth of july right yeah yeah yeah yeah
if you don't i'm telling you right now
we're gonna have a we're gonna have a
brendan shop situation
okay that's very funny he's already yeah
if you don't invite me tonight don't
edit that out
that's the worst thing i could say to
somebody right that's the worst thing
you could call somebody now he's leaning
into it yeah it's the worst thing i
could say
that is the worst thing i could say he
could have a job all right all right so
be [ __ ] careful dude my daughters
love bread
that's very funny my daughters love
brendan
you're [ __ ] kidding me right now dude
who that who doesn't do that you're
[ __ ] kidding me right now dude
oh god oh oh oh [ __ ] oh my god he just
shows up with really expensive cars
that's the remember they always say he
always shows up at the comedy store with
the really expensive cars and parks up
front
yeah because it's open season now for
him and he all his
i think at this point it was one of
those things where after i think rogan's
like yeah man you have to go i think
he's stopped protecting him that's what
it seems like right
it seems like the king
has decided like yeah i'm done with this
guy i'm not i can't protect you anymore
brendan i'm sure there was a phone call
i guarantee you there was a phone call
you're a big boy now yep i think there
was a phone call where joe rogan called
brent and he goes
what are you doing man
what are you doing
are you going after bobby lee
you know
i i'm telling you right now
i hate that picture that's [ __ ]
horrendous what is that
um all these other comics are really gay
like all the time right
yeah like everything they do is like
super gay i don't think that's noon like
a new thing
uh
then you uh oh wrong one
where is it where is it where is it
where is it uh here it is
[Music]
by the way again this is from two
buttons on my dad was super smart so he
was selling like brandon schopp's dad
was super smart you could tell because
of how smart he is yeah
my dad
was super smart so he was selling like
computer programs at the time he got
about [ __ ] early late 80s 80s okay
and he would go door to door like
pursuit of happiness you have a
briefcase he'd always have a suit on man
that doesn't sound like a smart guy
your dad sounds like a [ __ ] loser did
brennan fall asleep on a plane watching
a pursuit of happiness and now he's
going to add that to his lore
because who is can i ask a question
in the night in the late 80s
who was going door to door to houses
selling software
that's a good point
right like that doesn't make it i mean
i'm sure there were some but
looking like he was always into fashion
like always looked like a [ __ ] dime
piece
did he just call his dad his dad a dime
piece did he just call his dad a dime
piece yeah
he thinks his dad was hot yeah you want
to [ __ ] your dad brendan's sexy dad
oh that's going to be a chat name and
you go dota dora selling them and
sometimes me and my brother would follow
him
and then uh
he sold um
some software okay the software
and then i remember him on the phone
he was on the phone and he was jumping
is he
about to cry is he gonna
cry are you gonna cry brandon
put around and he's he's jumping around
and i'll never forget the cord was all
tangled around him and he's like we made
it he made him
who are these people that just said
damn
we
sorry sorry sorry sorry
we we all shared that experience we
heard the story we didn't take this out
of context right
did anything he say would would would
you your natural reaction be
wow
damn bro your dad sold something from
his job that he was supposed to sell
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] balls oh my god honey
i'm not gonna be home late
i just heard the most amazing story
somebody just said chills
so this is the are you garbage podcast
with kevin ryan and h foley
i feel bad every time we cover stuff
like this these guys no i know but then
they're always friends with people we're
friends with
are we friends with these guys i'm not
dan but i'm pretty sure these guys were
on um i maybe i'm wrong
were they on boys cast
maybe they were i don't care who's
friends by the way
is the guy in the left fat julian from
trailer park boys really does
yeah or fat ron swanson ah that's
another good one yeah then two days
later
he had a princess go back go back and go
back because we
really you cannot
understate forget about the dam
but i i want you to hear what else he
says and i forget the cord was all
tangled around him and he's like we made
it he made him
i just got chills and then two days
later i just got chills dude why would
that give anybody chills dude i did i
got chills there were the douche variety
yeah you but you like when you say stuff
like oh man why these guys you know
these guys might be friends with the
boys cast or whatever i don't give a
[ __ ] if that's ryan long's brother i was
ha
i know i know i know i know you're a
jugger yeah i wouldn't care if that's
brian long's [ __ ]
long lost father that just says i got
chills i would look him dead in his eye
and go your father's a dumb douche
ryan knows his dad they have a great
relationship
later
he had a printout the only problem that
i've heard that the leafs from when i've
heard that ryan long's dad has what he
tells he doesn't like that he keeps
hanging around with that jew danny paul
yeah
all these houses he goes which one do
you guys like
what was the matter what happened
what was the matter what would happen he
sold uh he sold his uh like the the
thing he was working on this big
computer thing okay
he sold this thing that he was working
on
this hold on merch wait don't make that
face i can see you don't make that face
imagine he sold look okay not only he
did but he went back i just squeezed my
eyes shut so tightly that i was seeing
stars
you are seeing a star it's brendan shop
not only that he closer to your dad was
a door-to-door computer software
salesman but he also invented the
software yeah he used to work at nct
software
you see that was just a
computer pioneer software developer and
salesman i'll give you fifty percent of
a dime piece and a towel god i forgot
about him being a timepiece merch bro
and honestly i hate these two other guys
more than brenda cause they're like
hyping this story up like it's the
greatest story in the world
they're acting like brendan's telling
the story of a time three home invaders
kicked in the door and tried to rape him
and his mother and his dad
single-handedly fought off three dudes
even though he'd been stabbed 50 times
that's the kind of thing where you could
go
damn dude i just got chills like that's
[ __ ] crazy
you know what happened he sold uh he
sold his uh like the the thing he was
working on this big computer thing by
the way if it was such a think about
this for a second right
if it was such a important day in your
father's life that you remember like
every detail
you don't remember what it was that he
sold it was a big uh you know this thing
he was working on a big computer thing
no but but you would think right like
the way he's talking about it he lies
like a kid lies like remember when you
would be in middle school and some kid
would make up some crazy story and you
know yeah and you'd ask him for a one
minute detail and the whole story would
break just fall apart immediately it's
like a big computer thing that he was
working on
okay sold at some big company
damn
and that was it you guys
bro whoa dude damn what a [ __ ] answer
what's this what it's like hey merce
what'd you have for dinner last night
uh last night i actually had uh some
tendees chicken tendees from publix and
uh and i had two uh pickle spears i just
got chills
like
be honest you do want pickles though
yeah actually that i see more [ __ ]
chills than this [ __ ] brendan story
of sword of god gore's head brand oh
hell yeah now we're talking can we just
talk about boar's head instead of
breathing had made it where everything
worked out yeah
i didn't know he has had a fat
transfusion okay
okay fair enough
what was going on because i was young
and i remember i was like oh i like that
one i thought he was just i don't know
yeah you know there's a guy like that
one you remember my dad just pulled a
slip and fall on a tgi friday yeah i'm
like really this one
i'm wearing cleats
now what are we stealing from this
hashtag yeah
we're robbing houses now
yeah you just but he just said that
he just said that what are we stealing
and then
he's doing the thing he used to always
do to brian
if brendan shop didn't steal jokes he
wouldn't have any jokes
that's the thing
like it would have been a better joke if
he said what are we robbing houses now
dad then you could go yeah what are we
like case in this joint that's a
slightly different variation of the same
joke but you just he just went but what
are we stealing from this house you said
yeah what are we like robbers now well
it should have been wasted for this
house what are we the wet bandits that's
the better line right
we got to bring mom onto this can we
stop and get a chocolate shake
what what what
comedically i'm asking
what is that what is having a stopping
to so in this fake comedic world that
these
brendan dude does like he riffs and does
improv
the way i improvise dialogue when i'm
still asleep
it's just you know like when you just
woke up and somebody starts like nagging
you about something and you're just
throwing words out there
you're like yes
yeah by the way you could say you don't
have to say someone's nagging you could
say me when we went to new york
royce did get a few mornings where
nothing i said made any sense i know i
really was fine wherever we're going
yeah we're going to be on road that's
actually one of the things that bird
said i go hey get up we we got to go to
lewis's show and he's like okay fine
i'll get a milkshake
get a milkshake on the way to rogan it's
nine in the morning and we're not doing
rogan we're doing lewis's show
we're doing the other bald guy with an
anger problem show
he uh
yeah
the other mma obsessed bald guy with
that yeah that's the show we were doing
so i was like that one then two weeks
later we pulled up to the house he's
like you and your brother go pick a room
yeah yeah oh yeah bro i just got chills
down
ah
what is so hyped
what's the show called again frozen
are you garbage the pursuit oh yeah well
the answer is yes
okay
the show is garbage hope that helped
i hope that helped that's [ __ ]
awesome man it was like pursuit of
happiness all right yeah my dad that's
all right all three of us gonna be
crying in a minute
i am i am i am about to start crying if
this [ __ ]
void of humor doesn't stop yeah maybe
you all need to get off the [ __ ]
antidepressants and try holy [ __ ] jesus
christ ssri the show over here what the
[ __ ]
should we get milkshakes or something
[ __ ] call this the benzo podcast
a bunch of [ __ ] over here i apologize
man no i apologize man
is he doing that billy crystal jazz
musician
i grew up as a little negro boy
in the streets and islands
my dad was will smith and he used to go
door-to-door like pursuit of
happiness how fatty was the house
uh
it's interesting right because he still
lives in that house it is interesting
at the time you know i didn't grow up in
that environment it was at the time it
was like to me the home alone house it
was the biggest thing i've ever seen
okay
so he judges houses based on the
home alone house
well the home alone house is dope yeah
yeah that's true is there any really
more dope midwestern house in america
than the foam alone house
i always like the house from the movie
the toy the richard pryor movie
okay that was that i watched that movie
as a kid right so i was like bro that
kid has a [ __ ] like you know an
entire like toy room and like all these
cool toys and [ __ ] that's he's awesome
now i've made my own way you know a lot
of credit to my dad and a lot of credit
to your dad joe rogan
your father joe rogan
you know now that you fit three of those
houses in my house
wow bro he's flexing on his dad yeah
now my dad's a [ __ ] loser now who's
the dime piece pop yeah
now you can suck my dick no seriously
your dime piece and then i go home and
my wife makes me pick off a gun
pick up
i go back and i'm just like damn this
isn't that was crazy well so yeah the
perspective of like you're in a
two-bedroom
this house ain't [ __ ]
wait um
you know you just turned this this
little tail of like where everybody was
tearing up and
literally was like what did the guys say
i got chills dude yeah
wouldn't wouldn't the cool twist the end
of that story be like and now i got all
these this big-ass house and i got all
this like these cars and [ __ ] but like
man every time i go back to that house
there's just something more special
about it right like isn't that something
you'd say no it is true yeah you'd go
you know my dad's house is smaller and
[ __ ] but like when i go back there man
there's no feeling like being back at
that old house here's what you're saying
i could buy [ __ ] ten mansions and
it'll never be as cool as yeah
exactly you say something you always say
something like yeah it was a two-bedroom
home but in my it'll always be a mansion
to me like that's like a you know but
instead it's like my dad's a peace [ __ ]
[ __ ] loser who sucks now you did it
wrong royce
you'd say that house might be small
but it'll always be on the incident oh
there it is there it is yeah and then
everybody's like oh man that guy's so
sensitive and then he doxes these people
and sends reddit after them
set the [ __ ] game up sell some more
software dork let's see i haven't
confirmed this but i i so i don't want
to get too into because i have to i
literally just got right before the show
but
rumor has it that somebody that works at
thick boy has been directly doxxing and
going after people on the fighter and
the kid read it
well that's a rational reasonable way to
handle things so if anyone has more info
please let me know i hate it
call this making it
i can't even park my cars here set your
which you can't park you know you yeah
you can print it could park the cars
here for you if here is the front of the
comedy club
yeah
oddly enough if there was any justices
in this world brendan's job for a living
would be parking cars [ __ ] seriously
he should be going on a [ __ ] joyride
in matthew broderick's car
oh my god that's wild huh
you would go go door-to-door like
pursuit of happiness you have a pretty
sort of slappiness oh that's pretty
funny this is by the way i try to point
out this is two buttons
two buttons does some good edits yeah he
really does he really does okay
so ariel helwani which is i believe in
one of an mma broadcaster like podcast
he had beef with brendan's job yeah but
did you see brennan doing a live read
and then ariel helwani doing the same
library for the same company making fun
of him
because you're about to download the
draftking sportsbook app right now use
promo code shop at five dollars on any
nba team to win their game during the
playing tournament and get 150 in free
bets instantly that's promo code shobb
at draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nba
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
supply ch see show notes for details
but to see show notes for details that's
that was the quiet part out loud
we have done a lot of live rates since
we've done this show
many
first off let me point something out my
book at that age is way better than
draftkings so let's just say that
because they pay us
forget him just reading it like ron
burgundy
listen to imagine you you pay right you
pay for a live read and this is what you
get the draftking sportsbook app right
now use promo code shop at five dollars
on any nba team to win their game during
the playing tournament and get one
hundred tournament pantomime this is
masking
and fifty dollars in free bets instantly
that's promo code shobb at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nba minimum age and
eligibility restrictions supply ch see
show notes for details see next page for
directions for disclaimer
he's so stupid
he's so goddamn stupid
holy [ __ ] man he is dumb
so this is ariel helwani doing his live
reading it also sucks but you know yeah
no i don't like him either but this is
funny
a while back when they had their beef
somebody was sending that stuff all the
time like you need to cover this
but um the only reason i never brought
it to the show was because i didn't even
do it on nightwave because
people were like look at this drama
going on and it was literally like just
10 minutes of burial helwani whining it
wasn't even good it wasn't even like he
was going in on brendan so you got to
watch this he's going in on brendan and
i watched it it was him just whining
yeah
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code dmr but five dollars
on any nba team to win their game during
the playing tournament and get 150
dollars in free bets instantly that's
promo code dmma hour at drafting
sportsbook unofficial
it's sports betting partner of the nba
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply
see show notes
for details
turn the page for more notes
[Laughter]
that's funny i don't care that is funny
what what did i say i didn't do anything
what are you talking about frank
you're such a [ __ ] joke brendan
you're such a [ __ ] joke yeah when
when ariel helwani is done yeah exactly
what i was gonna say when that's the
dude that's dunking on you
you got big problems buddy man brendan
sucks on so many levels in every level
on every [ __ ] level
and that concludes the brandon chop
coverage you can't even tell an
endearing anecdote about his dad without
resisting the urge to dunk on him
yeah i know
wait what is this
did i have one more
oh wait wait wait wait taper
resume the brendan shop coverage i
forgot there's one more thing i wanted
to play because he's going to be
clipping this so
[Music]
yeah it's you know my therapist it's
funny my therapist is like you know what
your problem is this is giannis papa sky
or whatever on tom segura show the
problem is you care too much about what
people think i'm like
yeah yeah do you not see what i [ __ ]
do for a living of course what do you
want me to stop caring about what people
think then i'll just go out there and be
one of those sociopaths who comes up and
goes crowd's great and everyone's like
you just pop
it's like i don't care what people think
i think we know who you're talking about
they are all turning on him who could it
be that he's talking about
baby but therapist told me not to care
yeah now i'm a full person he's like
yeah now you're a horrible comedian yeah
not caring about what people think will
make me a horrible comment and i don't
buy any of those [ __ ] guys that say
that [ __ ] either the ones who are like
you know just don't give a [ __ ] it's
like you know you do you do you do this
because you do yeah i
think we know who you're talking about
you know what that means i've done it i
love podcasting you know that was him
talking [ __ ] about him before they were
on air
and then bringing it up again but
without saying his name that's exactly
what it was
and now that concludes the brennan shop
coverage of the show for now
oh don't worry there'll be more